I have the new Microsoft Zune HD and
sure it's a Zune but the key is it's
thin it's cool-looking it's not the big
blocky thing with the skwerkel it's a
touchscreen and it's the best looking
screen I've ever seen on a portable
media player it's just awesome it's a 3
and a 30 inch LED take that Wow
I wish I had a screen that large but I
don't I have the new iPod Nano this is a
different from old nanos because it has
a video camera in it it's supposed to
compete with small form-factor cameras
like the flip and the the kodak it
doesn't have HD video in it though VGA
which actually looks pretty good on a
smaller screen but if you put it I don't
know on a larger screen like your zoom
there 16.9 screen probably isn't gonna
work it doesn't look it doesn't work
quite as well tell me about the smart
guides as yours have a Nike Plus all
yours cool can you keep track of your
steps can you know track your weight no
I am - do you have an FM tuner yes I do
have that oh yeah they put in FM to
turret there that's awesome very the new
iPod do you have an FM tuner
I do have an FM tuner do you have an HD
radio - you know oh I'm sorry
because I do and that's pretty cool
because you know the HD radio thing you
can not only hear like the regular
stream in a digital signal but the last
stations have a second stream and so a
station might have their regular
programming and then some auxilary cool
stuff on a second channel so what does
that mean for me does that mean like
everything's gonna sound better to me or
is that just like more options both oh
oh take that today ok so what's what's
your least favorite aspect of the museum
it's a great hardware but I wish it had
Mac software because the zune software
actually is pretty good it's pretty good
for music discovery so you find new cool
stuff to listen to and if you don't have
a PC or aren't running in sort of
virtualized on a Mac so I can't fight if
I'm not running the virtualized Mac I
can't plug that in if you're not running
a PC somehow you can't
do you know what my least favorite
aspect once this is the lens for this
guy should be right smack dab in the
middle here and it's actually offset to
the side I cover it up with my finger
every time I try to take a video this is
actually available right now for my
Apple comm 280 bucks 16 gigabytes I
encourage you if you're an exercise nut
if you want to take some sweet video and
if you want to have a robust market
place to download music and video I'd
recommend a 16 gigabyte iPod Nano all
right and Zune HD can buy it starting
today 32 gigabyte version is 289 10
bucks less than the iPod Touch no I not
quite as robust a marketplace for video
and apps yet but they're all coming and
if you want a great screen this is what
you need to find it
it will output high-definition if you
hook it up to the accessory dock